so there's human nature
to what degree
does communism
uh a lack of exploitation of the working
class naturally emerge if you leave two
people together in a room and come back
a year later if you leave five people
together in a room if you leave a
hundred people and a thousand people
it seems that humans form hierarchies
uh naturally so the the clever the
charismatic
uh the sexy the the muscular the
powerful what however you define that
uh starts
start you know becoming a leader and
start to
do
maybe exploitation in a non-negative
sense a more generic sense starts to
become an employer
not in a capitalist sense but just as a
human here you go do this and in
exchange i will give you this just
becomes the leadership role right
so the question is yes okay it would be
nice
the idea sort of of communism would be
nice to
um
theory but it doesn't work in practice
because of human nature because of human
nature that's thank you
so what what can we say about leveraging
human nature to achieve some of these
ends
there's so many ways of responding
in no particular order here here are
some of them
um the history of the human race
as best i can tell
is a history in which
a succession of
social forms forms of society
arise
and as they do
they
rule out some kinds of human behavior
on the grounds that they are socially
disruptive and unacceptable
the argument isn't really then
is there a need or an instinct is there
some human nature
that makes people want to do this
well whatever that is this has to be
repressed or else we don't have a
society
you know and freud helps us to
understand
that that repression is going on all the
time and it has consequences it's not a
finished project you repress it it's
gone it doesn't work like that
so for example
when you get a bunch of people together
at some point they may develop
animosities towards one another that
lead them to want the other person or
persons
to disappear to be dead to be gone
but we don't permit you to
do that
we just don't
every economic system that has ever
existed
has included people who defend it
on the grounds that it is the only
system consistent with human nature and
that every effort to go beyond it
has to fail because it contradicts human
nature i can show you endless documents
of every tribal society i've ever
studied every anthropological community
that has ever been studied slavery
wherever it's existed i can show you
endless documents in which the defenders
of those systems not all of them of
course but many defenders used that
argument to naturalize a system is a way
to hold on to it to prevent it from
going
to counter the argument that every
system is born every system evolves and
then every system dies
and therefore capitalism since it was
born
and since it's been developing
we all know what the next stage of
capitalism is looking infer
if what you're saying the burden is on
the people who think it isn't okay so it
doesn't mean they're wrong but what
you're saying is if we look at history
you're deeply suspicious of the argument
this is going against human nature
because we keep using that for basically
everything including toxic relationship
toxic systems absolutely destructive
systems
you